so what is the best treatment for those annoying
eye floaters that 70% of the population has
well it's a very simple and inexpensive solution
it actually is going to be free but let me
just first explain what an eye floater is it's a
strange little worm-like cobweb piece of something
in your eye that tends to float around especially
if you try to focus in on it or when you look away
now it's not dangerous but it's just annoying
what it actually is is a piece of collagen fiber
that creates a shadow in the back part of the
eye the retina that gives you this image and
this usually comes from some type of breakdown
tissue in the inside of the eye whether it's from
internal bleeding or some type of inflammation
from white blood cells now ninety percent of the
time it's from the aging process it could be from
some old injury an infection or some blood sugar
situation because diabetics or pre-diabetics
normally have a lot more eye floaters than people
who don't because high blood sugars directly
affect the eye it actually breaks down eye
tissue but regardless of all that the solution is
autophagy for those of you that have been watching
my videos in my channel you know what this is but
if for those of you that are new autophagy is a
condition where your body is recycling old damaged
protein so your body is taking these old proteins
recycling them and making them into new proteins
and the biggest thing that stimulates this is
fasting so a combination of intermittent
fasting and periodic prolonged fasting like
72 hours or even 48 hours every so often would be
the absolute best thing you can do to help get rid
of these floaters now there's no studies on this
that i have found but you might want to try it
because not only is it not expensive it's actually
free but you'll see a lot of other benefits that
go beyond just getting rid of your eye floaters
so if you're new to my channel i put a link down
below of exactly how to do this hey before you
go real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free
course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today